>> Okay, so we agreed, Michael, that
the problem's pretty hard. It's exponential in
the number of features in this case N. And there are sort of two general
approaches that people have used to try
to attack this problem, broadly speaking. The first
is called filtering, and the second is called wrapping, with a W, not an R.
>> Hm.
>> Well, it has an R too, but it starts with
a W. And they actually look pretty similar. So I drew these
little cartoons, which I hope would, would make it easier for
you to see. So filtering basically works like this. You have a
set of features as input. You run them through some algorithm
that maximizes some kind of criteria. And then it outputs fewer features.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And passes those to some learning
algorithm, that willl then use it for classification,
say. It could be a regression, more generally,
but you know, without loss of generality let's
assume that we're worried about classification problems here. So
you'll notice then that the criterion of how you know
whether you're doing well or not is buried inside the
search algorithm itself. By contrast, you could do what's called
wrapping. And in the wrapping approach, you've taken your set
of features, your N features, and you run them into
this little box that basically searches over a subset of
features, asks the learning algorithm to do something with them.
The learning algorithm basically reports how well it
does. And it uses that to update this new
subset of features that it might look for, and
passes to the algorithm. So, this is called filtering
because this is a process that filters the
features before handing it to a learning algorithm. And
this is called wrapping because the search for the
features is wrapped around whatever your learning algorithm is.
>> Hm.
>> You see that?
>> I think so.
>> Okay, so you might ask yourself,
okay great, so you got two different approaches to this. Which one might
you pick? And, unsurprisingly, there are tradeoffs. So, let's talk a little bit
about what those tradeoffs are. Actually, before we do that, Michael do you
have any suggestions for what would be
good or bad about filtering versus wrapping?
>> So filtering, it feels like is how we
were talking about it before. It's this idea of whittling
down to a set of fewer features and then
handing it over, kind of one thing after the other.
I, an advantage of that seems like it's sort of very flow
forward, right? So it, it, the features come in, the search does its
thing, it hands it over, everybody's got its job. The disadvantage of
that, though, is that there isn't any feedback. So the learning algorithm can't
inform the search algorithm as to hey, you know, you gave me
this feature, but without that, you took away that feature, but without it
I'm having a lot of trouble doing the learning. Maybe you should put
that one back in. The second, the wrapping approach, I guess, would allow
for that.
>> In fact, that's exactly right. So as I
said before, in the filtering case, the criterion or
criteria is built inside the search algorithm itself without
reference to the learner. By contrast, in wrapping the
criteria, or criterion if it's a single one, is
actually built inside what the learner wants. It's built
inside something like classification error, or sum of squared
errors, or whatever it is you measure the learner by.
So we can write those down and then stare at them for a little while.